françoise hostalier bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors pour
commencer ce plan de paix pour la vague
dany ce temps voulu par l'administration
maiden finalement est-ce qu'il est
réaliste selon vous alors j'ai d'abord
vous dire quand on a envoyé cette lettre
j'ai cru que c'était une fête qui news
je me suis dit c'est pas possible c'est
un scud envoyé par l'équipe trump contre
la diplomatie américaine actuelle qu'est
ce qui nous attend c'est serré c'est
qu'est ce qui vous fait dire ça quand
vous qu'est ce qui vous fait dire ça
quand vous lisez cette lettre mais c'est
absolument aberrant fin j'étais
stupéfaite comme beaucoup de d'autres
personnes qui sont bien intéresser et un
petit peu au fait de la faire de
l'afghanistan du contenu de cette lettre
et surtout de ton comminatoire d'un
simple secrétaire d'état américain donc
ses dires un ministre des affaires
étrangères à un chef d'état d'un chef
d'état élu légitimement même s'il a été
un peu mal élu donc je veux dire c'est
le taux est absolument incroyable
un toit s'est pas une lettre oui donc à
toi incroyable et derrière quelle est
l'intention américaine que vous
comprenez l'intention américaine c'est
maintenant vous allez arrêter de
tergiverser et vous allez nous obéir
vous allez faire donc premièrement la
paix avec les talibans bah oui mais ça
fait depuis 2014 que les pourparlers
sont engagés avec le mouvement taleb
c'est barack obama qui avait commencé il
faut quand même le rappeler et si tout
cela piétine
c'est simplement du fait que les
talibans ne veulent absolument pas céder
en rien par rapport à leurs exigences de
mettre en place la charia et de pouvoir
prendre entièrement le pouvoir en
afghanistan
ils ne veulent pas partager le pouvoir
et c'est absolument inacceptable pour le
peuple afghan de revenir vingt ans en
arrière et cela donald trump finalement
l'avez compris oui alors on était tous
contents un ou pour beaucoup de voir
arriver une nouvelle
équipe à la maison blanche et on s'était
dit que nous les français notamment
qu'avec monsieur antony blinken qui est
francophone francophile on allait
pouvoir enfin discuter sérieusement de
la politique américaine notamment la
politique étrangère et on se rend compte
que malheureusement les américains n'ont
rien compris de leur histoire ils n'ont
rien compris de leur histoire c'est
quand même eux qui avaient amené les
talibans c'est quand même eux qui
avaient permis à oussama ben laden de
s'installer en afghanistan il faut quand
même le rappeler et là ils sont en train
de recommencer le même scénario mais
cette fois ci ce sont pas les talibans
qui vont faire problème ce sera des ch
parce que les talibans ne respecteront
pas leurs paroles contrairement à ce que
pense peut-être monsieur blinken les
talibans ne respectent pas leur parole
parce que ils s'estiment que donné leur
parole à des mécréants ça ne c'est nous
seuls ça ça n'a pas de valeur
donc quand ils prétendent oui on
n'empêchera les autres groupe terroriste
al qaïda ou des jeux de s'installer en
afghanistan c'est c'est pas vrai et de
toute façon ils y sont déjà
donc si les taliban par malheur reprenez
le pouvoir en afghanistan
d'une part ce sera la guerre civile
c'est bien ce qu'a dit monsieur aura la
salle est un donc le vice-président
afghan qui a dit que de toute façon ils
ne tiendraient aucun compte de cet
ultimatum américain et de et dans
d'autres régions
eh bien on risque de voir la
prolifération de mouvements comme dèche
donc je pense que même pour nous les
européens cette situation est
extrêmement périlleuse et dramatique
et est ce que ça veut dire que joe biden
va maintenant maintenir des troupes en
afghanistan et que l'accord finalement
de février 2020 entre américains et
talibans et bien aujourd'hui est caduque
non je crois que c'est le contraire je
crois que c'est le contraire enfin dans
la lettre qu'elle telles que je les lui
donc c'est vrai que monsieur donc
blinken menace de revenir sur
l'engagement qu'ils au kiel a pris par
rapport au maintien des troupes mais
c'est dans le sens 2 si vous ne nous
laissez pas on ira on partira plus vite
et bien moi j'ai dit aux américains oui
partez
partez et partez plus vite possible
parce que maintenant trop c'est trop
l'armée nationale afghane est
parfaitement capable de résister à une
éventuelle offensive des talibans de ce
problème c'est qu'il faut que l'aide la
communauté internationale continue
évidemment à apporter une aide
financière et une certaine aide
logistique notamment dans le
renseignement et dans le soutien aérien
par drones mais pour le reste
pour le reste faisons confiance aux
afghans pour savoir ce qu'ils veulent et
pour savoir protéger eux mêmes leur pays
ça fait 20 ans que les américains sont
en afghanistan quand il fait depuis 20
ans c'est une bonne question
quand il fait depuis 20 ans là monsieur
monsieur blinken donc ordonne au
président achraf rani de s'arranger avec
son ancien opposant donc abdullah
abdullah de s'arranger avec monsieur
karzaï qu'a fait monsieur karzaï deux
fois élu président en afghanistan on a
vu le résultat et surtout de s'arranger
avec le professeur sayyaf qui est
reconnu par les heures les organismes de
défense des droits de l'homme comme
étant lui même un oeil aux heures de
human rights voilà quelles sont les
références aujourd'hui de monsieur
blinken de plus ces dons allez je vous
en prie tandis que je vous posais une
question ensuite sur we all blues il y
avait lié à dans cette lettre un affront
à la communauté européenne puisque
monsieur blinken
donc dit que d'ici quelques semaines il
va demander à donc ankara d'organiser
une rencontre donc de manière à pouvoir
définitivement résoudre ce problème aux
turcs aux turcs
je dire qu'est ce que les turcs vont
faire dans cette histoire
si c'est pas parce que les turcs sont
donc membre de l'otan
que l'otan et donc la puissance
militaire donc deux caisses qui
intervient en afghanistan c'est pas les
américains c'est l'otan qui
interviennent avec en afghanistan et et
que c'est juste pour faire un don qu'une
manchette à l'union européenne et
notamment à la france
alors j'avoue que là qu'on touche de
courrier on est complètement stupéfait
en quarts aller les russes ont été
conviés également quel est le rôle de la
la russie la russie at elle un rôle à
jouer dans ce dossier la russie je pense
je pense que poutine doit bien s'amuser
c'est fin c'est horrible de dire ça mais
de bien s'amuser de voir la situation
parce que demandé aujourd'hui aux russes
enfin que les américains demandent aux
russes et aux iraniens ils vont convient
aussi les iraniens de venir au secours
de la situation en afghanistan
c'est quand même quelque chose
d'extraordinaire bon je pense que de
toute façon ni les russes ni les
iraniens ni les pakistanais qui sont
quand même les uns des protagonistes les
plus les plus que les plus prégnants
dans cette dans cette situation ni lait
ni les chinois ni les indiens n'ont
attendu
monsieur blinken pour essayer de
résoudre le problème
donc je veux dire le problème les biens
à la fois bien plus simple et bien plus
compliqué que ça bon donc se dire c'est
pas par des ultimatums
c'est pas en claquant des doigts que
l'on va réussir maintenant à résoudre ce
problème et c'est surtout pas en
humiliant un président de la république
et de la république islamique
d'afghanistan et lui qu' on va réussir à
trouver une solution
merci beaucoup françoise hostalier
d'avoir répondu à nos questions dans la
matinale de rtl france je le rappelle
nous est présidente du club france
afghanistan ancien député du nord
également ses deux ministres